I know how this works brother that's not
my first interview I know how hmm the
best surprise I had this year was the
surprise for not only myself but for our
television show blackish and for Tracee
Ellis Ross all being nominated for Emmys
this year and then when neither one it
was one that hit me I got him a bob that
was good sprout someone asked me it was
like is that your metric for success
having that vehicle and I was like no my
metric for success is picking my
grandmother up and having her roll
around the back seat and taking her
through the projects that we grew up in
in watts since that grandma this is
where it all started and look at us now
that's my metric for success being able
to do that what was your question again
my best performance I believe might have
been an episode of blackish entitled
hope and our children need to know that
that's the world that they live in you
know I think that's what we pride
ourselves on with our show being
authentic and telling these stories as
truthfully as we can on a universal
scale that episode in particular but I'm
proud of all the work that I do with our
show not only me but my entire cast as
well
best outfit of the year I'm gonna say I
wore I hosted this little show called
the BT Awards and I gave a tribute to
Prince and I came out an all-white and
white lace with my ass out I have a
beautiful ass and I wanted the world to
see my beautiful ass they made me a mean
large say they made my ass and me best
outfit one by yours truly
the best tweet of the year when I had to
check Donald Trump saying he did not
know Sam Jackson he'd never met him does
too many commercials and not a fan
and it's stemmed from a story of Sam
Jackson saying Donald Trump cheats at
golf we were playing golf and I shake my
ball to the left
Donald hit his ball he shanked his ball
further to the left
Donald's ball was 20 yards to the right
of where I was looking for my boss
sitting up on the most [ __ ] slide
no I'm not gonna say Donald Trump cheats
at golf but if your caddie cheats for
you does that mean is your cheat or - I
had to go on and correct him with my
tweet it was like Donald what do you
mean you never met Sam Jackson we had
hot dogs and shrimp for lunch at the
turn which I thought was an interesting
combination best advice I received this
year was from my mother and her advice
to me was baby come live your life it's
like okay mama
we have to live our lives for ourselves
we can't live them for other people's
approval and we have to be true to where
we are and be honest with ourselves
you